our shout out tonight to an
investigative reporting team at the
Dallas Morning News that has spent
months of the last six months looking
into one family's claim of police
brutality it was the family's word
against that of the police no one was
killed
and it's the kind of incident that might
easily get lost in the press of other
news but not for these reporters it was
on a late afternoon last August when
police in the Dallas suburb of DeSoto
responded to a report of a heated family
argument as the police dash camera shows
everything was calm when the first
officer pulled in that was about to
change as the Dallas Morning News
reporters discovered the cops came in
and overheated they they brandished
their weapons for pointing their weapons
that everybody started screaming at them
to get down on them the video shows
Sammy Anderson the mother of four
brothers who had initially asked for
police to be called trying to restrain
one of her sons as more officers arrive
on the scene and tensions continue to
escalate before long police would use
their tasers against at least one of her
sons
leading to a claim of police brutality
Dallas Morning News investigative
reporter miles Moffitt an engagement
reporter LV le monde heard about the
incident from the local civil rights
group and began to review the police
videos
I mean you could see a lot of you know
aggressive actions on their part and the
family being very confused asking
questions themselves not immediately
responding to their orders to get on the
ground as you can imagine because they
didn't understand why you know the their
actions were so aggressive and also
again pointing tasers at their face and
it's been out of control
so the dash cam it had presented a
fairly confusing sequence of events the
family later told the reporters they
felt they had been brutalized and had
only called the police because they
trusted the officers to calm the
situation not make it worse this family
told us that they had so much trust in
their Police Department you know they're
from a suburb so most of the time you
know they see at the police all the time
the reporters could not clearly make out
what exactly happened given the wide
angle view from the patrol car dash cam
but they also knew the solo police were
supposed to wear body cameras so you
know it became really imperative to get
the body cams so we could have close-up
detail it took months before police
released the body cam video so we get
the body cam and the body cam you know
is is murky one video is black the
officer was wearing it
and during the tasing at least four
cameras were were not activated and we
don't know why leaving lots of questions
about just how many times in this scene
grant Bible one of the sons was
subjected to taser
[Music]
[Applause]
that night he suffered a hemorrhage to
his eye and his mom says she believes
her she saw an officer activate his
taser close to his head
so the question is did his eye injury
come as a result of the tasing and what
else was happening what else was
happening on that that closely-knit
crowding but with what body cam footage
they could obtain the Dallas Morning
News photo editor Marcia Allard had
videographer Brad Ellis put together a
compelling synced up version of what
happened it was actually Marcia's idea
she said I think we need a Steven
Soderbergh like effect here and what she
was saying is the multiple perspective
so viewers themselves can draw their own
conclusion the timeline clearly showing
how the situation so quickly escalated
at the hands of the officers the police
chief says his officers acted properly
but one result of the Dallas Morning
News reporting was that the district
attorney dropped all charges against two
of the brothers who were arrested that
night although it took months for that
to happen some of the brothers lost
their jobs because they were in jail
when this happened
as for the DeSoto Police Department
we're still waiting for some kind of
response from them and so far we were
just not hearing back but thanks to the
reporting efforts the two brothers at
least have now been cleared of charges
that should never had been brought in
the first place yeah it feels really
good we were able to go to the
courthouse and just kind of see them
release some balloons the day they met
the two brothers picture we - yeah we're
exonerated and you know they it just
feels like a weight off their shoulders
no doubt a great feeling
so our shout out tonight to the team at
the Dallas Morning News for showing how
investigative journalism can make such a
difference sometimes it means people who
break the law end up in jail but it's
even better when journalists help people
wrongly accused and help them get out of
jail
I've seen that again many times in our
reporting so once again hats off a shout
out to the Dallas Morning News for some
great work that's our program tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you
again right back here next week